there is an urgency of now Prime
Minister of Barbados Mia Motley talking
to youth activists on a mission to get
rich countries and fossil fuel companies
to pay compensation for the harm done by
climate change
it's called loss and damage and it has
become the defining issue of this Summit
the oil and gas companies are resisting
the wealthy nations are resisting can
you actually get it done I believe so
the evidence of the science is clear the
inequity in the world is just as
apparent Justice is simply about fair
play and solidarity without solidarity
small countries small people like Mika
make it there was a time when women
couldn't make it they had to come
together the suffocates to be able to
get the solidarity to get the war the
world continues to see different battles
come at different times I believe that
this is a conversation whose time has
come the idea is gathering momentum
Africans
is responsible only for around four or
less than four percent of the climate
change Banks
96 Plus
is a developed World they've damaged our
environment
but we are not saying we'll take them to
court no because we are one Community
we're simply saying it's the right thing
to do we absolutely have to find the
money to do this we have to serious loss
and damage is now on the table if you
look at what's happening to the global
South it is heartbreaking but for those
pushing for change there is one large
hurdle in the way the problem is that
many of the wealthy Nations here at this
Summit have only agreed to talk about
the idea of loss and damage they haven't
actually agreed to do anything yet they
are very reluctant for example to open
up a new funding facility preferring
instead to funnel cash via existing
organizations like the United Nations
campaigners say that's no longer good
enough we don't have any time to keep
talking about it because people are
over 30 years ago so we can still keep
talking about it we need to see instant
action right now on loss and damage
for some this is an uncosted unrealistic
and unhelpful distraction from the work
of reducing emissions but it is
dominating the conversation here and its
supporters want to keep it that way
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in charmel
Sheikh in Egypt